all right so i'm going to finish up some
of the things that i talked about with
experimental design last time and then
we're going to get on and talk about
category selective regions in the cortex
which of course we've been talking about
in various ways all along but i'll raise
some general controversies about that
some alternative views from the kind of
one that i've been foisting on you
and what i consider to be some of the
strongest
most important evidence against the view
that i've been putting forth here
and then we'll talk about decoding
signals from brains okay that's the
agenda here we go okay so last time i
had you guys work in groups to think
about experimental design because really
most decisions about experimental design
once you know the bare basics of the
measure measurement methods they're just
applying common sense thinking about
what it's like for the subject
how are you going to get the data you
need
so in terms of what exact conditions to
run in any experiment
i talked about the idea of a minimal
pair this kind of platonic ideal of the
perfect contrast which never exists in
reality but that you aspire toward so
ideally you want two conditions that are
identical except for the one little
thing that you're interested in
okay and you don't want to have other
things that co-vary with that thing
you're manipulating other than the thing
you're interested in and that's the crux
of the matter in experimental design
okay
you guys talked about what kind of tasks
have subjects do in the scanner there's
a trade-off between kind of doing the
most natural thing which is they're just
lying there and stimuli come visual
auditory whatever
versus the fact that subjects might fall
asleep if they have nothing to do and if
they fall asleep you won't know and
that's not good
so it's sometimes better to have a task
to keep them awake and to tell you that
they're awake
a key important point
don't have one task for one stimulus
condition and a different
task for a different stimulus condition
if you did that would be a
sorry
confound exactly that would be a
confound okay don't do that
um we talked about baseline conditions
um so for example in a vision experiment
staring at a dot or a cross is a kind of
as as far as you can go in turning off
your visual system why would you want to
bother with that um well it's sometimes
useful um to have that kind of baseline
because we want we sometimes want to
look not just at a difference between
two conditions remember one condition
alone in mri tells you not a damn thing
all we can see is differences
but even just two conditions showing you
a difference that's something but it can
be ambiguous so for example if you had a
situation like this where there was a
response in some brain region to the red
condition here in the green condition
there they're just two numbers that's
all you have
uh that is different
that's kind of meh you know there's a
difference but meh right but if you have
a good baseline and you really know that
zero is zero
um or as close to zero as you can get
and now imagine if zero was here
that'd be like wow that's a really
strong effect and especially in
neuroscience where we care a lot as you
may have noticed about selectivity about
how much more we get a response in one
condition than another and cell
activities are usually more interesting
as a ratio than as a difference as i'm
illustrating here
and so you can't get a ratio unless you
have a third condition usually a
baseline
all right
a few other things
we talked about how you allocate
subjects to conditions
you could have all your subjects do you
know one half of the subjects do the
face condition for an hour in the
scanner another half of your subjects do
the object condition for an hour in the
scanner that's no good we don't want to
do that we want to within subjects
design we want all the conditions within
a subject whenever we can do that
why well my best analogy to this is
suppose we decided to grade your
assignments as follows
a third of the class is going to be
graded only by heather
this third of the class is going to be
graded only by dana across the whole
semester you guys are heather people you
guys are dana people you guys are anya
people is that fair
no that's dumb
what if heather's a hard ass and she is
kind of a hard ass right
[Laughter]
not that you guys aren't they're they're
all the pretty tough crew there i stand
here just waiting for the gong to go
wrong and you guys should do that i'm
sure i've already said wrong things and
you know it so next time sound the gong
and correct me anyway
that wouldn't be fair in grading exams
and neither is a good and experimental
design so for all the same reasons that
you guys can hopefully get an intuition
here you want to have all the conditions
within a person because maybe one
person's brain just activates more than
another person's brain maybe this person
had more coffee coffee increases your
bold response
we give away free espresso beans
chocolate espresso beans before scans in
my lab to increase the mri response
okay
all of that do designs within subjects
whenever possible
okay how do you allocate conditions to
runs these kind of subsets of a whole
hour-long experiment where you scan
people for maybe five minutes at a time
and give them a break and another five
minutes
well the same logic applies
imagine you're in a scanner for an hour
you're getting sleepy you're getting
bored you're thinking about other things
you're kind of not on the ball those
things change over slow periods of time
and so you want to get all those
conditions together within a run just as
you want to get conditions together
within a subject whenever possible
okay
okay and so then we didn't really get
into this and i think you did in your
groups but
how do we stick all these conditions
together within a run do we clump them
together in a batch or we do we
interleave them and i think most of you
guys realize that there's a there's this
deep set of trade-offs there
um and so you know here's a block what's
sometimes called the block design where
you clump a condition a whole bunch of
trials with one condition then a whole
bunch of trials of another with in this
case some kind of baseline in between
right
versus a mixed interleaved condition
which is called event related for
uninteresting historical reasons
um
and if it's event related you can have
it slow or fast okay
so why
what what are the why wouldn't you
um what are the reasons okay what are
the reasons to do this rather than that
many of you guys came up with this last
time so
nothing earth
sorry
minion lights on biases yeah yeah what
kind of biases
in a blocked
experiment they might be biased by what
they've
been looking for yeah all kinds of
biases like consider this trial here in
a yellow condition well you just did a
bunch of yellow trials so maybe your
yellow system is adapted out or
something or biased somehow but you also
know that the next one's going to be
yellow and there's all that previous
stuff and
anticipatory stuff all on top of the
actual effect of a single yellow trial
yeah was that what you were going to say
is
yeah all of those things the effects of
recent history doing the same thing and
anticipation of the future all on top of
what actually happens in this trial okay
so those are not deal killers but
they're you know things to be aware of
so those are reasons why you might want
to go with this condition or this
condition
why wouldn't you always do this
alternate the order and not alternate
randomize the order
of conditions over time
um and bunch them in together why is
that not always a great idea
people do that sometimes it's not a
terrible idea but there are things to
keep in mind here what's the challenge
with that
yeah one possible
challenge is that the bold response has
like a 10 second window so it doesn't
describe delete exactly so these
the bold responses here are going to be
massively on top of each other
that's why people sometimes do this it's
like okay we'll have a random order and
we'll put a big chunk of time in between
but if you have to stick 10 seconds in
between trials
your subject is going to fall asleep and
you're wasting you're spending all that
expensive scan time you know not
collecting enough trials right so
there's you know none of these is right
or wrong they're right or wrong in
different conditions okay
so as okay am i saying it right okay
um as i mentioned the challenge here let
me just give you my crude depiction of
this so let's suppose you have a this is
time a series of trials with a house a
dot a face a dot a dot i don't know
where that i want to face the house etc
and each of those trials is one second
long
okay
well let's imagine the response in the
fusiform face area to that first house
you get some kind of middling low
response that's going to take many
seconds to peak
okay let's look at the response to this
face well it's going to be higher and
it's going to peak out there
okay and so then you can look at the
response of each of these things right
and so you get this whole series
of bold responses from each of those
different trials
okay
but now
here's the problem what we observe when
we measure the response of a
little voxel a little three-dimensional
pixel in the brain
is the sum of all of that something like
this it'll be higher than that but some
big blurry sum of all that
so now we want to go backwards from
observing this
to seeing the difference between that
and that
and that's a problem
okay
so
that's not great but here's the crazy
thing
it's not impossible
it's not impossible
because by weird mysterious to me still
kind of unfathomable
um
physiological mechanisms these things
add up approximately linearly it's
really counterintuitive who would think
a big sloppy biological system with many
different causal steps could produce
something that is approximately linear
but it does
and because they add up linearly if you
have enough trials you can take this
thing and recover that and that
okay we're not going to go through the
math of it it's just basically addition
it's like solving for like you know
it's it's solving for um you know
multiple equations because you have all
these different time points did
everybody get the gist of the idea that
even if you're observing something
really slowly varying and weakly varying
because it's massively blurred you could
in principle with enough trials go
backwards and solve for that and that
everybody get that idea
okay so what that means is
it's a bit of an uphill battle to do a
fast event related thing like you can't
just look at the response you have to
actually do a lot of math and you may or
may not have enough trials to pull it
out
right but under some circumstances where
you really need things to be interleaved
you can pull that off
okay
all right
so that's what i just said blah blah
blah okay
a few other design things that i didn't
really talk about in detail
one i've mentioned glancingly but i
wanted to be more explicit about it this
whole idea that we've talked about a few
times of defining a region of the brain
that we're going to look at with a uh
with a localizer scan okay with
functional mri we talked about that with
the case of characterizing face areas go
run a face versus object scan find the
face area in that subject and then do
new experiments and test it
right or when you guys proposed your
snake experiments you said first
localize a candidate snake specific
region with snakes versus non-snakes and
then do repeated tests in that region
that you found in each subject
why do we have to do all that within
each subject you don't technically have
to lots of people don't but the reason i
think it's important and the reason we
do it in my lab and all of my
intellectual descendants do that and
lots of other people do too the reason
we do that is that that region is not in
exactly the same place in each subject
okay
so
i have a dopey analogy brains are
physically different from one person to
the next
if we scan you guys just anatomically
and look at the structure of your brains
your brains are as different from each
other as your faces are
that is you all have the same basic
structure the same major lobes and
sulcide just as you all have eyes and
nose and mouth but they're in slightly
different positions and that's just the
anatomy the function on top of that is
even more variable okay
so
uh it's like trying to align faces right
so no matter if you have a bunch of
photographs of faces and you try to
align them on top of each other and
superimpose them even if you have a few
degrees of stretch you can't do it
perfectly you'll get some kind of mess
like this right they just they're
different so they don't perfectly
superimpose
right well it's the same deal with
brains you try to align them perfectly
from one person to the next but they're
physically different they do not
perfectly superimpose
okay
so
but you know so now imagine that this is
totally crazy analogy but it's best i
could come up with suppose you're a
dermatologist and you're interested in
skin cancers that arise in the upper lip
what could happen there's more sunlight
hitting the upper lip whatever okay so
now you can take a whole and you're
studying photographs to try to see how
many people have it or something like
that
so you could take a whole bunch of
photographs and you could just say okay
i'm going to look right there
it's usually going to be the upper lip
but it's not always going to be the
upper lip and so you're really throwing
away a lot of information by
choosing the wrong location for this
person down here you missed it right
you're looking at the wrong thing okay
so in the same way
if you want to study that region you've
got to find it on each individual
photograph and similarly if you want to
study the fusiform face area or the
snake area which doesn't exist but
whatever um you gotta go find that thing
in that person individually otherwise
you're really blurring your data just as
those data are blurred there make sense
okay
all right
um
good okay
different topic about design these are
just kind of different topics i couldn't
find a good segues
so far we have been talking about the
most rudimentary simple possible
experimental design that means two
conditions
faces on and objects snakes and
non-snakes moving or stationary whatever
two conditions where you contrast and
you look in the brain is there a higher
response to a than b okay
nothing wrong with that you can get
pretty far with this
but first of all of course we can have
more than two conditions so you can have
one factor in this case stimulus
category
with many different conditions
right
aces bodies objects scenes whatever
right okay so that's not
rocket science we've just added a few
more conditions
of the same factor your factor is the
you know the dimension you're varying in
this case it's stimulus type okay
but we could get fancy
and we could have four conditions
that are two factors varied orthogonally
like this
okay this is sometimes called a two by
two design
uh we're going to vary one thing on this
axis and another thing on this axis
okay
why would we want to do that
well let's look at an example
now let's suppose that you were going to
compare
faces to objects in this case chairs
but beyond just those two conditions of
comparing the response in the brain when
people are looking at faces versus
objects we could now ask does a response
in the brain to faces and objects
depend on whether you're paying
attention to the faces and objects
what if you're paying attention to
something else
what if
we have little colored letters right in
the middle of the display and they're
changing rapidly over time and your task
is to monitor for a repetition of a
letter a one-back task and it's going
really fast so it's very demanding
you're just looking at those letters
they're flashing up a little two b's bum
you hit a button boom it's like very
demanding okay the information hitting
your retina
is still coming in from the face because
the little letter is tiny it's not
hiding much of the face
what do you think if you're doing the
letter task do you think you'll still
get a response in the fusiform face area
when the face comes up and will it be
higher than when the chairs come up
any intuitions yes
talk to me about that
it should be because
i think what we've learned is the
signals once it hits the medium and so
still coming in
yeah will it be just as high
what do you think
no i don't think it'd be as out but it
doesn't since your response that's like
higher than
effort everybody see how this is kind of
an interesting question right the
machinery is the same all the feed
forward stuff is the same you can't when
i tell you just now you're doing the
letter task now you're doing the face
task when you switch to the letter task
the wiring in your brain doesn't change
all the same wiring is there that's it's
a stimulus is still hitting your retina
it's still going up the system so it
becomes interesting to ask how could it
be different right would it be different
all right i just want you all in the
grip of this is a question that we might
ask
so how could we ask this question
um well
um
we can do as i just said we can have
subjects in one case do their standard
object task look for repetitions of fa
of con consecutive repetitions of a face
or of a chair we have all different
kinds of chairs but every once in a
while
two in a row are the same okay
um or we could have this other task
where they're monitoring for letter
repetitions so does everybody get this
two by two design
on one factor
we're varying
the stimulus is it faces or objects
and on the um faces or objects those are
the two conditions it's just terminology
okay
um and on the other factor we're varying
um tasks are you doing the the face
object task or the letter task yeah ben
is it okay so what is it that this task
was like what conclusions to allow you
to draw the
simpler customer good question good
question
anybody have an intuition here you mean
other than just doing that never mind
the letters
yes exactly
exactly the right question
what do you guys what do you think is
there any reason to do this does anybody
care about this
what would it tell us
yeah i forget your name
lauren yeah the effect of attention on
perception yeah
yeah so if we want to know not just is
there some bit that responds more to
faces and objects we've been doing that
for weeks enough already right we know
there is okay now we want to know
does it matter what you're paying
attention to
is that thing like a just like a is it
like a little machine that's going to do
its thing no matter what
or do you the perceiver have any control
over it here's another version of that
question
you guys can all sit there and look
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and look at
me and smile and nod and think about
whatever you want to think about and i
won't know
you could be bored out of your mind
thinking about
you know what you did last night
whatever and i won't know and that's
great i mean isn't that nice that we
human beings are not trapped by the
stimulus that's in front of us at any
moment instead we can control our mental
processes to some degree
right and if you choose to think about
something else you go for it you have
good judgment that is fine it happens to
me all the time you have that ability i
have that ability not really when i'm
lecturing i kind of have to stay on task
that's why it's exhausting but anyway
um
but you know we are not trapped we are
not completely controlled by the sensory
world impinging on us and that's a good
thing
and so if you wanted to find out about
how that works and study how well we can
control our own mental processes you
would do something like this make sense
okay
all right
okay
so this design
enables us
to ask a whole bunch of things
one
does a response in some region or voxel
or wherever we're looking
depend on stimulus category okay this is
what we've been talking about for a
couple weeks now
that by to do that you could just say
okay is there an overall higher response
to these two conditions than those two
conditions you wouldn't worry about
tasks you say overall
is there a bit that likes faces more
than objects okay everybody got that
that's one thing that's sort of what
we've been doing so far is just
comparing
two levels of one factor that's called a
main effect okay
in this case a manifest effect of the
factor stimulus type
all right
or we could ask a different question
does the response of a region of the
brain
depend on attention
so overall never mind whether it's faces
or objects there's like photographs
flashing up there does it matter if
you're paying attention to those
photographs or paying attention to
something else
okay
so for that we compare the average of
these two versus the average of those
two that would be a main effect of task
make sense it's just terminology but
it's important to see that we can ask
these different questions of a two by
two design
okay
ready with me anybody want to ask me
something this one this main effect
isn't a very interesting one it's kind
of a weird one but you could you could
do it right
okay
um
okay so that's yeah main effect of
attention or task okay
now we could ask as someone else said a
moment ago was that you lauren yes
if we want to know
does the effect of stimulus category
depend on attention
that's what a two by two design is that
is that kind of question that a two by
two design enables you to ask
so to ask that question
really what we would do is essentially
look at this row and then that row and
then we compare them
so we might say how much higher of a
response you get than for faces and
objects and we get some number in that
cell
sorry when you're paying attention to
them
and how much would you get when you're
not paying attention to them you're
paying attention to the letters and then
we could say oh
what is it you know how selective is the
face response when it's attended versus
unattended in other words how do the
response to stimuli depend on task
okay it's not rocket science but it's
important to see how this humble little
two by two enables you to ask these very
different questions so this question of
how the effect of one factor depends on
the level you're at with the other
factor is called an interaction
okay
um
and it's often like the most interesting
kind of question to ask of any kind of
data whether it's mri or anything else
you could think of it as a difference of
differences
right
or
more directly how the effect of one
factor
depends on the level of the other factor
okay in this case the terminology would
be we'd be looking at an interaction of
stimulus category by task
make sense
everybody with the program about how
this question is different than the two
different main effect questions
okay
to get some practice with this
i'm going to have you guys come up here
and draw some data
okay so we're going to consider
um okay we're going to just to get
experience with main effects and
interactions we're going to consider a
main effect of factor x which is an
overall effect of x i the difference
between condition one versus condition
two within x and we're going to consider
interactions of factor x and factor y
that is how um
how the effect of x depends on y and
vice versa okay so i'm going to have you
guys draw data i need my first volunteer
this is not hard uh how do i put this
thing up
i forgot to check if i have red and
black pens hopefully i do
if you don't volunteer i'm gonna pick
randomly
and that could be worse
it's not too awful
is it carrie
unfortunately i remember your name so
what up here
um
okay so
um
you got an easy one
uh
this doesn't write very well but it will
do
okay this is your red pen that's your
black pen
um okay so
we have here the response in red or
orange will be the attended case we're
looking at a response in the fusiform
face area
a possible response in this case a
pretty unlikely one but never mind
so the attended one and there's the
unattended one and there's response to
objects and faces and what i want you to
draw is a pattern of data in which
there's no main effect of stimulus type
no main effect of attention and no
interaction of stimulus type by
attention
so just put you're going to draw four
dots you can do x's and o's or whatever
okay so
no effect of the stimulus so that means
it doesn't matter if what's the base or
option uh-huh exactly so
i guess you could do that for one to go
do that for the attended task first so
do that in red
you have to really
lean on it oh it worked for me
sorry we'll have the extremely
counterintuitive thing of
this is the tension there we go here you
go
okay perfect no main effect of stimulus
type good
okay now we've got no main effect of
attention
so take the blue pen
so this is like
and no interaction no effect of
attention relative to
attention no attention that's right no
no main effective attention means no
difference for attended and unattended
okay
but stimulus type is important
no no we're still it's all the same
we're drawing all the same situation
yeah exactly it's a little bit of a
there you go beautiful nicely done
carrie okay so that's kind of a dopey
case well done you can sit down yeah
okay so we're just starting basic here
okay that's what it looks like if you
have no main effects and no interactions
everything's the same
okay all right
that's not going to happen if you're in
the fusiform face area if you get that
there's something wrong with your scan
or something went way wrong okay but
we're just flushing out the logical
possibilities okay i need the next
volunteer who's going to do a main
effect of stimulus type no main effect
of attention and no interaction of
stimulus type by attention
yes come on up here
is it
what's your
name sorry aquali yes right
um great so go ahead and draw that for
me
i'm just gonna clarify that this what do
we do this is unintent wait a minute
yeah unattended here
okay
here you go
there's a main effect assuming it's
probably easiest if you start yeah start
with the tendon there's a main effect of
stimulus type
great you're in the ffa the faces are
going to be higher than the objects and
main effect of stimulus type says you're
going to get a difference good
beautiful well done make sense everyone
thank you kwiley
um
that make sense everyone okay so
what would this mean if you got this
okay quality you're not quite done so
you get that what's that telling you
um
it tells you that uh
it responds to
the stimulus but
the the attention
doesn't make any difference
yeah
the the the selectivity you get doesn't
depend on attention in this case again
these are all we're just making up data
right we're just considering the
different ways the data could come out
and what they would tell us everybody
got that
okay
now the plot is going to thicken a
little bit
now we're going to have a main effect of
stimulus and main effective attention
and no interaction of
stimulus by attention
it's going to come up here
satalia one up here
here you go
beautiful
thank you
everybody see how this is a main
effective stimulus type faces are higher
than objects a main effect of attention
attended is higher than unattended but
no interaction
the effective stimulus type is the same
at each level
yeah
just something that made it was unclear
is the
does the tension usually affect the
selectivity or the average response
these are great questions right now
we're just considering the logical
possibilities okay we will talk about
that later yeah it's a good question you
should be wondering
yeah
okay so um talia tell us if you found
that
what would that mean
um
so because like
the difference in effect between like
intended and unintended like objects and
faces is the same like that does show
that like a tension like plays an effect
and the stimulus vision effect but
there's like no interaction between them
because like the difference is the same
it's like there's these two different
things there's face selectivity and then
there's just a big like overall if
you're looking at stuff you get higher
responses and if you're looking at the
letters yeah exactly
all right one more
i need a volunteer
david
that's not a volunteer i realize it's
different than a volunteer but
okay so draw me a case where you have a
main effect of stimulus a main effect of
attention and an interaction of stimulus
by attention
yeah
beautiful
so here we have um oh wait actually hang
on hang on hang on
uh wait a second you've got a main
effect of stimulus
actually you don't have the main effect
of stimulus here did i get rid of that
yeah you got rid of that
now you have the main effect of
attention
wait maybe i said oh maybe i told it
maybe i said it wrong oh yes you didn't
have a okay wait a second
oh yeah you're right
i think i screwed you up here okay we
want a main effect of stimulus yeah yeah
and then
well let's let's just
if we move it a little bit like that
exactly okay so don't go away um does
everybody see how this is a main effect
of stimulus those guys are higher than
those guys
a main effect of attention the grease
got green guys are higher than the blue
guys
but an interaction like that difference
is bigger than that difference
okay now don't go away david
if you got that
what would you conclude about the
fusiform case here if you got those data
well
the ffa
if it was like this it depends
if not only does it depend on attention
but it depends on attention more than
uh maybe the object uh detection doesn't
depend on attention so much
that's right that's what your data show
is that the the response to faces is
more strongly affected by attention than
the response to objects
but another way of saying the same thing
is to say that the selectivity is
greater
when you're attending than when you're
not attending
make sense
or the differential response is greater
okay
great thank you everybody got these
basic ideas
okay they're pretty rudimentary i don't
want to insult your intelligence but i i
really i've found that people often
don't get main effects in interactions
and they're often really the crux of an
interesting design is an interaction and
keeping it straight from the main
effects sometimes takes a little
doing okay
so let's consider what is the key sign
of an interaction oh well we already
have a case where often people draw an
interaction where the lines cross but
they don't need to cross david just
showed you a nice interaction where the
lines don't cross okay
all right
okay
moving on that was all leftovers that's
bad planning oh sorry what oh yes put
the thing up good point or down
thank you chris
um okay let's talk about category
selective regions of the visual cortex
we've been talking about these all along
but it's time to get a little more
critical
um
so first i've been talking about how
there's a patch in there that responds
pretty selectively to faces
there's a patch out there on the lateral
surface it responds pretty selectively
to bodies
and we haven't mentioned it much but
next week you'll hear more than you want
to hear about a patch smack in the
middle there that responds selectively
to images of scenes okay
so
you just look at that and it's really
damn near impossible not to wonder what
else is lurking in there right what else
is in there
uh and of course we we wondered that
many years ago me and paul downing who
did the um the body area paper he was my
postdoc at the time and we said well
let's just scan people looking at 20
different categories of objects and we
put in all kind of silly stuff in there
i'm phobic about snakes so i wanted
snakes he's phobic about spiders we
compromised in our creepiest condition
threw them both in there it was kind of
sloppy but
we had food and plants because we
figured those are biologically important
we had you know
weapons because those aren't tools
because those are you know those are
important in other ways
we had flowers because steve pinker has
this line in one of his books saying
that a
flower is a veritable microfiche of
biologically relevant information
he hypothesized based on that that
people might have special purpose neural
machinery for flowers
sounded like a crock to me but it's an
empirical question so we threw flowers
in there for steve pinker okay
um and uh and so then we scan people
looking at all of these things and we
replicated in every subject the uh the
existence of selective regions for
places faces and bodies
and we didn't find anything else
none of these other categories produced
clear whopping selectivities
in systematic regions of the kind that
you see in every subject for faces
places and bodies
now i hasten to say that there are lots
of ways with any method to not see
something that's actually there
you might not have enough statistical
power to see it it might be that there's
a whole bunch of neurons that do that
but they're scattered all over the brain
and so they're spatially interleaved
with neurons that do other things in
which case mri will never see it
there are big black holes in mri images
where there are artifacts and you can't
see anything and if the soul was right
there we wouldn't have discovered it yet
because we can't see it in our mri
images not that i know what the contrast
is for the soul you could work on that
do you have a question ty yeah i'm just
curious did you try it on like cracks
yes and we will get to that later and
there is absolutely a specialized region
for text and we'll talk about that in a
few weeks yeah
we didn't in this experiment but we and
lots of others have
in other cases
um okay so um so don't take this too
seriously my main point is just that you
don't find a little patch of brain for
any damn thing you test mostly you don't
find it right
there is some disagreement in the field
about the case of tools and hands there
are many reports that if you look at
pictures of tools or look at pictures of
hands you can get a nice little
selective blob i have looked at both of
those many times i don't see it i don't
know what everyone else is on about i'm
confused about that i just leave that as
in play i don't know but with that
exception there's good agreement that
faces places and bodies everyone
replicates
and most of these others no one
replicates
and so in particular
nobody reports selective patches of
brain that respond selectively to cars
chairs food or lots of other things we
have tested snakes by the way and not
found anything
at least in the cortex
so what does that mean that implies
connoisseur
that some categories are special in the
brain
okay at least at this crude grain that
we can see
with functional mri
and that seems pretty interesting and
important yes i have a nice question
about places did you um distinguish
between newly made places and naturals
we'll get into all of that in
excruciating detail next week yeah it
doesn't really make much of a difference
it likes all of those things yeah
um
okay so i've been going around for 20
years saying see these these these
categories are really special in the
brain and the mind and that's what we're
getting from this and that's deep and
fundamental it's telling something us
something about you know who we are as
human beings or whatever sometimes i go
off the deep end with huge claims okay
but not everybody buys this and so what
i want to do is allude briefly to the
general kinds of ways you could argue
against this and then talk in some
detail about one main one
okay
so ongoing controversies
this view here is highly caricaturized
and this is actually not right right the
brain doesn't have completely discreet
little regions it's a mucky biological
system and if you actually look at the
part the face selective regions they
have ratty edges and little kind of
archipelagos of you know sub-blobs and
stuff it's kind of a bit of a mess right
there's a general cluster in that
vicinity in most subjects but it isn't
always
a discrete blob unless you blur your
data you take any any data and blur it
enough it looks nice and clean
but if you want to know the actual
native form in the brain on blurred it's
kind of mucky okay
so
one could react to that in different
ways my reaction to that is like what do
you expect it's a biological system does
it really need to be perfectly you know
perfectly oval shaped with a perfectly
sharp edge i don't really care if it if
it's interleaved with other stuff around
the edges
but people react different ways and one
kind of important alternative view is
look how do we know
these that these are really you know
things in the brain i'm talking about
them as things you know pieces parts of
brain and mind right
and you know maybe they're just kind of
peaks in a broader landscape of
responses across the cortex that are
fluctuating and empirically that's true
there isn't just like one butte and then
nothing else in the cortex around it
there's some kind of profile right so
it's a bit of a judgment call how
excited you want to be about a big peak
in a fluctuating background
yeah
and so there's much discussion about
that
is it really just a peak in a broader
spatial organization and if so
what is that broader spatial
organization all about right it just
pushes that question back it says we're
wrong to think about discrete things
but that still leaves many mysteries
about what that continuous gradient is
okay so that's kind of one
line of response which i think is
completely legitimate
um
any sort of version of that it kind of
blurs into this next view which we've
talked about a little bit and that is to
what extent can these things if i'm
calling them things
be accounted for just by their
perceptual features so we've grappled
with that in a number of ways so far one
of the first things we asked about the
face area is is it just responding to
curvy stuff
right or round things or whatever right
and so there are many
lines of work where me and many other
people have asked that question and for
the most part the answer seems to be
there's somewhat you know there's some
featural selectivities in these regions
but probably not enough to account for
their category selectivity
but that that one too was still in play
and there's this dude in english in
england who publishes like several
papers a year saying like you know no
this thing isn't category selective it's
just that
um i was going to assign i'm going to
try to assign one of his papers to you
because i want you to expose you to
alternate views but i haven't yet um i
haven't yet taught you the key methods
you need for that paper anyway so
there's room for debate in that question
as well
then there's just a continuum of okay
exactly how selective are these regions
like okay i'm excited if a face area
responds like this to faces and like
that to objects but hey it responds like
that to objects is that selective enough
you know so there's a lot of debate
about what that means okay so there's a
lot of room to push back on the
simple-minded story i've been serving up
to you guys
but what i want to do next is talk about
what i take to be the most smart and
serious challenge which is somewhat
different from all of these
okay
and this comes from a guy up at
dartmouth named jim hacksby
who published the paper that was
assigned for today
and i intended for you to like struggle
with it a little bit and try to
understand it but if you didn't
understand it fully i'm going to talk
about it here and hopefully that'll make
it more intelligible
okay
so here's the big idea that hacks be
there's many ideas in that paper but the
part of it that's most relevant to us
for now
is the following
even if the fusiform face area responds
weakly to chairs and cars
for in contrast with strong response to
faces
that doesn't mean that it doesn't hold
information about chairs and cars
okay
so all along i've been just talking
about one dimension does it respond like
this or like that and that's gotten us
pretty far
but the essence of hacksby's idea is
that we should care not just about the
overall mean response we should ask if
there's information present in the
pattern of response across voxels
okay
and his point is that even if there's a
low mean response
you could still have information in the
pattern across voxels even if it
averages to some low number
okay
and that pattern of information could
enable you to distinguish different
categories
all right so let's get very particular
so how exactly would you tell so here's
what hacksby did essentially or here's
my here's the subset of the assigned
paper that's relevant to the current
question
if we want to know does the fusiform
face area hold information about cars
and chairs thereby arguing against its
selectivity for for faces right i mean
we should care about information in the
brain not just magnitude of response
right if the brain is an information
processing system we care what
information the parts contain not just
house how much the neurons are firing
okay all right so if we want to know
this here's what you can do here's a
version of what hacksbee did
you scan subjects while they're looking
at chairs and cars
you've localized the fusiform face area
so you know where it is okay so now you
get the response this is highly
schematic
this is an idealized version of the
cortical surface remember the cortex is
a surface so we can mathematically
unfold it and look at the magnitude of
response of each voxel in the ffa ffa
isn't square but we're idealizing it
here okay everybody get how that could
be a pattern of response across voxels
in the ffa when the subject looks at
chairs okay
and maybe you have some other pattern
when the subject is looking at cars
now certainly if if the pattern when
they're looking at faces all of these
bars would be much higher
but our point is that even if these are
low they're different across voxels
okay so that's step one
so then what hacksb says is you do the
same thing in the same subject you do it
again hopefully in the same scanning
session and you get
another pattern
like this and this okay
now here's the key question
if there is systematic uh if those
patterns are systematic
for chairs and systematically different
for cars then there is information in
that region about the difference between
chairs and cars
okay
chairs and cars aren't faces so that's
an important challenge to my story about
how that region only does faces okay so
how do you measure that well there's
lots of ways
um haxby's is the lowest tech and most
intuitive he just says let's look at the
similarity of this pattern to that
pattern repeated measures on cars sorry
chairs same subject chairs on the even
runs and chairs on the odd runs
by the way why do you split your data
like this
rather than like this
okay he does eight runs
we could take the first half of the runs
put those data here in the second half
and put them over there or we could take
the data like this and take even runs
and odd runs why is even an odd better
than first half second half
yeah
uh i guess it doesn't allow like the
subjects to get used to like one
particular one particular thing one
after another well they're doing the
same thing it's all the same data it's
just how you analyze it
i'm not sure i think it's
probably easier to compare between
one time
and one face and the other it is
you can actually do it either way it's
like you scan these eight runs here they
are you can do that
i don't know if you can see what i'm
doing here with my whole crew or you can
do this
why is this better
than this
yeah as well um
yeah maybe they fell asleep halfway
through the scan
okay then if you do like this
the odd and even are going to be better
compared to each other
than first half second half right makes
sense
okay it's another version of why you do
things within subjects it's the same
kind of argument yeah
okay
so he splits into even and odd and so
you ask how similar are they within a
category within chairs
and within cars you get two different
correlation values just how similar are
those patterns you get an r value
and we compare that
with how similar the patterns are
between
chairs even to cars odd and chairs and
cars
even to chairs odd
okay
and so the key question you ask
if there's information
about chairs and cars in this pattern of
responses then the correlations will be
higher within category than between
category
in other words two different times you
scan looking at chairs those patterns
are more similar
than chairs are to cars
make sense i mean it's pretty it's
pretty basic but it's one of these
things that's
simple and yet subtle at the same time
does everybody get this
okay so you just do these repeated
measures and you look at these pattern
of correlations and if the the patterns
are more similar or more correlated
within a category than between
categories then you have information
in that pattern that enables you to
distinguish those categories
yeah
okay
so that's what hacksbee did
um yes so what was this information
doubles so it would be difficult to look
at
nothing really um well wait a second oh
that's the same okay that's essentially
like this
it's just that since we're going from
even to odd with the win within case
we're going to go even to odd in the
between case you could have done it this
way but then
yeah
okay
okay
so
um
that's the method what does hacks be
find
well you guys should all look at the
paper some more so you get a sense of it
it's actually really nicely written even
though it's dense those science papers
are very dense
but basically here's what happened so in
that paper he says yes he can
distinguish between
cars and chairs in the ffa
and therefore to quote from his paper
regions such as the ffa notice the
square scare quotes he's put in there to
diss me i i hear you i hear you jim okay
regions such as the ffa are not
dedicated to representing only human
faces
rather they're part of a more extended
representation for all objects
them's fighting words right everybody
see how this is a serious challenge with
a very elegant method
okay
so when i first read that paper it's
like huh okay i'm paying attention but
he didn't do everything right i didn't
like the way he defined the ffa i found
a million reasons to dis it and i ran my
own version and in my paper that we
published we did we could not
discriminate those we said
you can we can okay you did it wrong we
did it right
then a few years later
jim publishes a paper with a
collaborator in which they reanalyze
their old data and said actually you
really can't discriminate it very well
it was significantly above chance but
really lousy and so they concluded
preferred regions for faces and houses
that is regions that respond
preferentially to faces or houses are
not well suited to object
classifications that do not involve
phases in houses respectively
but i didn't get to gloat because right
about the same time we were redoing our
experiments at higher resolution and
actually we could distinguish
two different non-faces in the fusiform
face area so that was like the little
drama that unfolded and so the current
status is um yes like you really can
discriminate two different non-faced
categories within the fusiform face area
um even if you do it right even if i do
it right and i don't want that result
and i do it right i can get that result
okay so that's true empirically
the ability to discriminate is is feeble
it's not very strong but it's
significantly greater than chance
so
does that mean i'm toast and i wasted
the last few weeks telling you guys a
bunch of bs that has been disproven
and i should not have been telling you
yeah david isn't it it's kind of like
saying that you could use a vending
machine like a clock and
then asking the question then what is
this thing for
he said well it's obviously the office
clock that's a great a great analogy i
love that absolutely
absolutely
so now
to me
the central question and here's another
another example that i think is exactly
like that but but even more on point
and that is that there are deep nets
that people have trained on faces vgg
face it's really good at face
recognition it has only ever seen faces
it has only been trained on faces that
is all it's about
and if you feed it
chairs or whatever i have chairs and
cars
it can discriminate between chairs and
cars
so even if you have this perfect
representation
that's only been trained on faces that
has only evolved if it evolved we'll get
to that later to deal with faces
it can still give you a somewhat
different response
to chairs and cars and that doesn't mean
that that's what it's doing
right
so i think this is a really important um
challenge but i think centrally
crucially what we really need to be
thinking about maybe quilly has a
contribution
yeah so like if it's only been trained
on faces and you feed it and share
um like what's it out for them
um okay so you know it's just it's just
a bunch of feed-forward layers that are
connected with you know
boatloads of units at each thing and
connected in the systematic pattern and
once you train it up
you can feed it any stimulus and you can
collect the response at the top
okay
so even though it is designed for and
only been trained on faces you can feed
it non-faces and get the response out
this at the top and see but that is not
the not the category not not the top
layer where it says that's joe or that's
bob but just before that layer there's a
whole bunch of units that have some
representation distributed across units
you can take that
and try to read it out and ask if
there's information there okay i'm not
giving you all the details of how you do
that but hopefully you can get at least
suggest and later in the semester
katherine dobbs is going to tell you
more about how you do all this kind of
stuff
okay
i spent a lot of time in the last
last few weeks talking about a key
difference between two different kinds
of methods one set of methods
that allows this kind of inference and
another set of methods that allows that
kind of inference
i'm trying to give you guys a clue here
um
actually what i'm going to do is let you
percolate on this i don't think this is
obvious i worried about this for years i
think there are many answers to it
it's not cut and dried i will say i have
already presented to you at least two
different lines of work
that argue
that provide an important counter
argument to this
one of the people who gave me crappy
teaching evaluations last year said she
told us about counter arguments and then
made us tell her how they could in fact
after all be consistent with her data i
thought that was weird
i was just
i was just trying to teach people to
think about data but anyway i won't make
you do that because somebody didn't like
that before
but you can think about it and we'll
talk later and actually i'm gonna i it's
actually good to think about and we will
come back to it um but i want to get on
with the rest okay i mean i mention all
this because it is an important
challenge yeah and i'm wondering if like
objects are not processed in ffa they
must be processed somewhere else totally
so something else
totally i had a whole piece of this
lecture on that and then i thought for
once i'm not going to go over my time so
i'm not going to talk about that but um
yeah there are there there's remember
there's all those other bits of cortex
i've just identified a few particular
ones there's lots of cortex in between
and the simple statement is there's a
lot of nearby cortex near the ffa in the
ppa that seems to respond generically to
object shape
and the first pass guess is that there's
like a general purpose visual machine in
there in addition to some more
specialized ones
but i'm going to not say more at the
moment and i'll just say actually if you
read it you may read it in papers it's
sometimes called lo or loc that's kind
of shape selective region which is
arguably the kind of
generic let's process everything else
system okay
only if it's clarification questions
okay ask it
no i was just wondering which came first
this world called transcripts
sorry this work or oh
ah good question uh the transcranial
stuff has actually been going on for a
long time but the relevant kind that i
talked to you about is more recent and
you're right it is one of the very
strong answers to this kind of critique
there's several actually i've told you
about three so far
answers to this but think about it
okay
so um
okay so what we're going to do now is
talk about not just this particular
use of this method to ask a serious
question about the selectivity of
regions in the ventral visual pathway
now what i'm going to do is argue that
actually i think i just said all of this
what what hacksbee has given us is also
a method to ask what information is
present in this little patch of the
brain
and that's an awesome thing
so let's go on and talk about that let's
talk about neural decoding with
functional mri so that was an instance
of it but i'm going to cash it out in
another way more generally
so let's take the case where there's a
person with a patch of their brain and a
pattern of response across fossils
in that patch of their brain when they
look at some stimulus
let's suppose
you're given this
and you want to know
what was that person looking at
to produce that pattern
right what was the stimulus out in the
world that produced that pattern
can you do that
so
more generally can you read the mind
with functional mri
or maybe a little more honestly can you
at least tell what the person saw from
their pattern of brain response okay
everybody get the question here
okay
how can we try this well they're all
variations of that hacksbee method that
i just told you about okay but let's
walk through this
so the first thing you need is you have
this pattern and you're trying to figure
out what stimulus produced that pattern
in this and this person's in that part
of this person's brain
well you need a decoder
you need to know what those voxels
respond like when they look at different
things where you know the answer
okay so what you do is you scan the
subject on a bunch of different
conditions to get your decoder
and then you can take your unknown data
and compare it to those decoder data
okay so in particular
you have to train your decoder so you
scan the person looking at say shoes and
you get pattern
you scan them looking at cats and you
get a pattern maybe you scan them
looking at
five ten a hundred other things probably
not a hundred you don't have enough scan
time
but some number of things and so now you
know you know this is how those voxels
respond when the person looks at shoes
and this is how those voxels respond
when they look at cats okay
now
you test your decoder
with your mystery pattern
now you have your mystery unknown
pattern you want to know
was that shoes or cats
okay
well you can just look
what is it more similar to all the
methods are versions of that they're
just fancy mathematical versions of that
so what do you think that pattern what
produced that pattern
shoes
it's more similar to the shoe pattern
exactly you guys just did neural
decoding okay
so that's exactly how you do this
there are all kinds of ways of doing
this from just saying is this more
correlated with that than that that's
hacksby's version
or you can put a whole big fancy machine
learning rigmarole in there to do
pattern classification because that is
after all what machine learning is so
awesome at is pattern classification and
this is just a straightforward pattern
classification task train on these test
on that
is that is that sort of intuitive what
we're doing here okay
so that's the agenda that's the logic of
how we do this
um
and so does that work
well
a little bit
but you don't have to worry uh because
at least at the moment
um because there are a million ways
about 10 years ago i was getting called
up by um
legal types all the time because are
there are people going to use people
going to detect lies with functional mri
and i thought this was a total crack and
i was going around giving talks on all
the reasons why nobody has to worry
that um they're going to be compelled to
testify by having being shoved in a
scanner and have their brains read i
mean it's not a totally stupid thing to
worry about
but lest anybody uh i don't think this
will happen but lest anybody try to read
your mind against your will while you're
in an mri scanner you can totally foil
it in any number of ways one move your
head
two if they've got your head bolted down
move your tongue you totally mess up
your whole signal if you move your
tongue
okay
three do mental arithmetic you can
totally shut down whatever they're
trying to do if you think about
something else anyway so we don't need
to worry about it it's not good for
insidious kind of
legal efforts but it is pretty good for
science sometimes
okay
so there's lots of versions of neural
decoding with functional mri
so we've been talking so far about
decoding functional mri patterns of
response across voxels
um that's called
mvpa multiple voxel pattern analysis you
don't need to memorize that but when you
see mvpa in a paper this is what it's
talking about okay
but you can also do it with lots of
other kinds of neural data oh sorry
within mvpa you can ask it of a
particular roi in the brain region of
interest like v1 or the face area or the
body area or something else
but you can also apply it to the whole
damn pile of data from the whole brain
and say can i tell what this person is
thinking by looking at their whole brain
okay
beyond functional mri you can apply it
to lots of other kinds of data so you
can do monkey neurophysiology as we
discussed briefly last time where you
have actual
firing rates from individual neurons
and you can look at the response acro
you know the response of each stimulus
class to each neuron in a region of the
brain and you can do the same deal
running a pattern classifier or a simple
correlation method on the pattern of
response across neurons rather than
voxels everybody see how that's sort of
the same deal
just better
okay
or you can do magnetoencephalography as
we talked about stick your head in the
big expensive hair dryer collect
magnetic signals from all around the
head 300 channels and now those magnetic
signals are changing over time
so the cool thing about neural decoding
with with meg is you can say okay let's
take the data from just exactly 80
milliseconds after the stimulus flashed
on
and let's ask what can you decode then
what can you decode at 100 milliseconds
120 milliseconds you can see the growth
of information over time as neural
information processing proceeds by by
running the decoder separately at each
time point
okay i'm going to try to squeeze into a
future lecture
more talk about that because i think
it's cool and we're doing a lot of it in
my lab right now does everybody get the
gist of this at least
okay
okay so that gives you the time course
of information extraction
okay
similarly there's lots of different
decoding methods you can use as i
mentioned the kind of simple low-tech
hax-b style correlations or you can use
something called linear support vector
machines
or various other kinds of fancy machine
learning math
okay
to to to do those classifiers
okay let's take do i have time to do
this
i'm going to skip this
yeah we're going to skip that it's cool
but we're going to cut to the oh i don't
know we'll do it all we've got time
all right
um okay
so
pointed now that i waste all that time
deciding whether we had time okay we're
going to compare how well this works
when you do it on mri versus how well it
works when you do it on neurons and
monkey brains
okay
so um
so there was a beautiful paper a few
years ago that looked at this so the
question is here are these face patches
and monkeys that i told you about and
that david leopold will be talking about
at four o'clock today
and so question is this particular one
am one of the nice face patches up there
these guys wanted to know what
information is represented up there in
face patch am
is there information about different
individual face identities can you use
it to decode which face the monkey saw
okay
and so they did this experiment two ways
one they did monkey neurophysiology they
recorded from 167 different individual
neurons in that region and for each
neuron they measured its response to
five different faces
okay
in another condition they popped the
very same monkeys in the scanner and
they scanned them with functional mri
and they did the same experiment and
they measured the magnitude of response
of each of 100 voxels in that same patch
of brain in that same monkey and they
got the mri response
to each of those hundred voxels
and for each voxel to each of those five
phases everybody get that this is asking
the same
question how well can you decode face
identity
from individual neurons or from
functional mri in the same animal
and the answer is damn depressing
the answer is you can decode identity
really well from neurophysiology and you
can't do it worth a damn with functional
mri
big bummer
yeah
so that's a drag it's just what it is
presumably remember each mri voxel has
hundreds of thousands of neurons in it
so the real miracle is that we ever see
anything at all
and when we can't see the neural code
with the resolution that we need to to
tell whether it's got information about
face identity that's just because we're
averaging over so many neurons
okay that was my lament at the end of
the lecture
um on monday that there are so many
limitations in um human methods and
here's one of the key ones
okay
um what are the implications it sucks
anyway okay i want to get one more idea
out uh and that is
yeah to fmri or does it also translate
to vdgs oeg is much worse much worse oh
my god yeah yeah
um yeah the only thing that might be
better someday is intra cranial
recording but even there you usually
don't get enough electrodes so you need
these very rare cases where you have
very high density grids of intracranial
electrodes that some surgeon has decided
by chance to put on a part of the region
a part of the brain where you happen to
have hypotheses and you happen to be
incredibly lucky to test your
your hypothesis and that's very rare
did you have a question clearly no okay
um okay so i've been talking about
neural decoding and that's a way of
asking what information is present in
this batch of neurons or this bunch of
voxels and that's a really deep question
to ask for cognitive science because
we're interested in information
processing and we want to know what's
represented in each region it's really
the crux of the matter in cognitive
neuroscience
but we can also use it to ask in a
richer way about the nature of that
information in each region
okay so suppose we want to know what
exactly is represented there
we want to know not just that it can
distinguish
shoes from cats okay that's okay
but suppose we want to know how is it
doing shoes versus cats does it just
know for example the shoes are elongated
this way and cats are roundish and
that's all it's using to do its
classification in other words it's not
really shoes and cats it's this versus
that or something right
if we want to know how abstract those
representations are or how invariant
they are to variations in viewing
conditions
then we can do the following cool thing
we can train the decoder on one set of
stimuli and test on a different kind of
stimuli
okay
so for example we can ask
are those representations
of shoes or are there representations of
shoes that are invariant to
for example color and viewpoint chosen
just because that was the nice shoe i
could find
my was searching hour ago okay so if we
train on these and test on that is that
going to work
is it going to know that this is the
same kind of thing as that if it does
what have we learned about that shoe
representation
yeah it's kind of generalizable it's
very generalizable yeah different
perspective totally
totally it's not just this
it's something closer to shoeness we
don't know exactly how far it is that
until we test more conditions but
exactly we've shown that it's really
abstract and generalizable that makes it
more useful that makes it more
cognitively interesting we could even go
off the deep end and say okay
is it the concept of a shoe
we could scan people reading the word
shoe and ask is that going to work
okay
anja's doing experiments like that
there's various people looking at this
kind of thing
um and so you can ask at any level how
general or invariant is that
representation
okay
so neural decoders are not just like
gimmicks to try to say oh i can see and
for mec and read out you know what this
person saw there are powerful methods in
science to characterize mental
representations and to characterize how
abstract they are
you